take your socks off take everything my
muscle come off you cannot see me my
socks always come off or you can't see
me naked as offs you just can't see me
later
hi guys we're back again
subscribe to our patreon guys so a new
source of what's the word I'm looking
for income a comma that sounds that
sounds greedy it's like it's on you it's
an exclusive episodes they would drop on
there yeah and it's obviously you get
the other benefits but mainly is to do
with the the exclusive episodes you can
get some episodes ittle bit earlier than
everyone else as well when we're
dropping them so that's all good but
yeah this is another it's just another
platform to see your song and obviously
it's just mainly it's just to support
the show so if you like the show will
always need support kind of financial
support obviously but then again just a
little bit it just a little bit of just
support man just it's just nice so we'll
be getting support everywhere else
get some good support on the patreon as
well but yes nice to see us and there of
course support us if you like to listen
to just the audio and make sure you
subscribe and YouTube again like
subscribe hit that little notification
bed on there as well man same [ __ ]
different day brother let's just keep it
moving follow us on twitter as well goes
oh yeah [ __ ] twitter we just want it
interactive you guys as well especially
from people all over the world like I
love the a lot of the comments we get
currently get on especially on Instagram
they're not even from the UK a lot of
people are from Australia we've got had
a Canadian guy up a few times before
from New Zealand and it's a lot it's
just good to interact with people that
we're probably never gonna meet or ever
gonna see what hopefully you will if
this if this comes this turns out bigger
than we expect and but yet mind it's
just cool to see that everyone can just
be interactive and you know like the
same [ __ ] I'm gonna live in completely
different country continent and your mom
role actually low there's a good point
actually love hearing about people's
countries and [ __ ] yeah one Donnie from
[ __ ] Australia's and it's a picture
of a black widow yeah outside of his
work
what's that what's that bro big man I
won't live in there but yeah
interest I find that imagery so
interesting um but yeah man um anyway
what was I gonna say what were you gonna
say
I was gonna say she kind of relates it
kind of relates to what you were just
saying in terms of like connecting with
people and yeah and to people and stuff
like that in a weird way obviously
outside of our immediate circle I feel
like the people on the podcast who I've
never met
yeah never spoken to yeah but the
listeners and the viewers all that [ __ ]
I might apart from like my close friends
are my only real friends I know what you
mean
no because there's only people that
listen to this that actually know who I
actually actually are who I really am
but they're the only people that I open
enough with the people that I don't know
we're the only people that know me know
me
yeah like to know what I'm like and they
know how I act and they know my sense of
humor and I know what pisses me off they
know what they know when I like to rant
they know when like I'm feeling like
it's weird innit yeah like they know me
Bette better than 90% of the people I
interact with on a day-to-day yeah it's
crazy so thank you [ __ ] thank you
thank you buff because a lot of the
stuff I talk about here I would never
speak about work of course not I will
never speak of course not I will get
sent to HR immediately but it's crazy
because all the stuff you talk about you
guys probably talk about with your close
friends and we're just playing on a
platform where we feel comfortable but
we're not bum with in the same breath
it's a vulnerability but you know baby I
even have what I would consider one not
close friends but I have good friends
but I again wouldn't have a conversation
yeah there's conversations I've had with
good friends since we've been doing the
podcast yeah because they brought up
something I've said on here and then I
give them more of an elaboration in
person money if it wasn't for them
bringing it up in the first I never
would have never seen yeah um which is
cool man very very cool my [ __ ] oh I
didn't even tell you what my mum put the
[ __ ] podcast the other day that's how
I don't [ __ ] know I reckon is my
brother
I reckon is my
[ __ ] Bravo I've got big mouth but I
must have said to him like I must assess
to him what you call it I was out did
you tell he's Suze I found out she
clocked it I was like did you tell mom
about the [ __ ] vodka no actually this
was it because of you the other mum for
whatever when we had to record so we
recorded in my mom's house yeah a couple
months ago yeah and yeah when do you
remember when she was leaving the house
oh no no no no no no it wasn't when you
went there so a few days before I went
over there and just explained by our me
if you had need to borrow your house for
a little while she was out all to do
your podcast and I'm thinking hmm I just
I thought ignore it yeah so I'm there
all good or good or good and then the
other day she was like what did she say
I was round there again and then what
was it she we were talking about
something we would talk about something
the other day and basically she's like I
bet you can't wait I think I think is
well the isolation team will talk about
the isolation team so I wouldn't be
going around there to see her yeah she
was like oh you're probably thinking
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't have to see my mum
she's such a [ __ ] I was thinking yeah
and then she was like well I know you
used to call me a [ __ ] when he was a
teenager anyway and then I didn't bring
I didn't I in my back of my head I was
thinking she's trying to be clever yeah
he wants me to bite and say what you
talking about no one ever I never used
to be a [ __ ] but I did like yes you did
because I listened to your [ __ ]
podcast and you did call me a [ __ ]
because you said when he was a teenager
for was a [ __ ] or something like that
so I didn't buy I said I'm not going
anywhere with this like this isn't a
conversation I was on my way out anyway
I think this is not a conversation I
want to have and then she messaged me
the other day just just out the blue and
was like oh I see your podcast is doing
well I just want to let you know I'm
proud of you and all that kind of stuff
but try and be like try and be nicer
about me kind of thing innit
if you're gonna talk about me like try
and be nicer about me and I was so livid
I don't know why
so livid just I don't know why just I
was just annoyed I think it's because I
was kind of caught off guard and it was
something that she just sprung on me
randomly yeah I mean I think I was more
angry because I know she was trying to
get me to buy in person mm-hmm but she
didn't and then she left it a few days
and then message me out of the blue
about it which annoyed me because I felt
like in one way I was a bit like if
you've got a problem just say say
especially when you're clearly adhering
to it yeah in the moment yeah and then
the other side I was a bit like angry
bars are just a bit like at the end of
the day I say I say dis tired about my
mum when we were kids and all that kind
of stuff and yeah I will say that are
like ah I had issues with my mom over a
kid everyone did everyone didn't stuff
like that but like there's definitely a
lot I don't say yeah for one oh yeah of
course
well one alpha 2 is almost like again
this is more for me this is more my
medium so it may come across like I am
being horrible about so that's not
intentional this is just my medium it's
my outlet yeah he's my unrest it's a lot
of stuff that I went through as a kid or
the experienced as a kid yeah I did not
bring up to anyone apart from my brother
yeah me and my brother the only two
people that ever spoken about and I said
to you as well it's important for me I
thoroughly believe you like I said a
million times on hey if you can find the
funny in something yeah it no long has
the power to piss you off or to hurt you
away cause if you can find the funny
you're blessed because the memory of
that situation will always be funny it's
now as funny as no it's not the
situation on here River it involves her
or not now in the moment was a bad
situation you mean where every time I
brought up in here we've always laughed
the back always and now that when I
think back it I just laugh about it so
it's important for me to continue to
keep bringing up these things and if
they come across as mean towards her
then so be it in a weird way I'm not
gonna be disrespectful
yeah um and she's a good person I love
my mom very much but yeah that was a
weird kind of thing to have so when she
said about the I didn't say any of that
stuff to her just so you know
I don't think any of that stuff I just
said okay I
mrs. buck okay she would have been livid
she would ruin leverage because she
wanted you the same or she backs it was
there was it would have got ugly that's
the thing because it just would have
gone I just I just know it would have so
you have to left it but yeah at the same
site got me thinking like it is actually
lucky said out letting yeah it is
manically everyone needs it out you do
need your outlet mine and it's not even
and again if you can find the funny in
it boy then it's done yeah I don't need
to bring it up probably ever again yeah
of course because it's done now it's
funny in this bless and that's something
I want to continue to do not internally
just for my mom but this is everything
in life and I fear of course but yeah
man that was a weird
that was something I don't know creeped
me out creeped me out my mom's like a
podcast is doing well like we talked
about on here I don't need my mom here
in breath I don't need mom here in but
yeah speaking of that kind of stuff
something that you brought up recently
just in conversation yeah being when
we've spoke about before when I said
like how can you look at a dick of being
young yeah
like when I think about what that's what
it was that's what it was that's what it
was that video you sent me this is one I
had a that tick-tock video you said with
the other day when that one guy was
doing interviews with random us on the
street and that one chick was like he
was out what kind of guys you attracted
to and she was like big guy and I was
like big as she was I yeah won't big
guys only time to sit the [ __ ] down shop
obviously I was a sick thing sexy sexy
with a capital K sexy but I was thinking
like how to be a woman or Otto be a
submissive man wherever I physically
cannot comprehend the attraction in
being choked out yeah thrown about yes
spread apart beat up if you are a woman
if I was a woman
I imagine yeah one thing that no say
physically imagine wanting that from
someone because every every woman's got
a rape fantasy every woman but the thing
is there is a threshold like so some
people's threshold might be at the start
of rape not like rape plus April like
this is all they can take and some
people are here and some people here but
every I feel like every woman has a
right bro they all do and it's funny you
mentioned about the threshold I never
had a girlfriend back in the day um this
is this is when you're young you're
trying to mix [ __ ] up yeah so let's see
what she like bro we're trying to spice
it up what and then she I think she
thought she wanted that fantasy and real
real life she did it didn't want
anything to do with it cuz I remember I
think I had I think I was in six warm
yeah I was in six warm
yeah and we were just after 6 1 we were
just [ __ ] around cheering in my room
about to get down to it she's talking
all this crud yeah and I'm not all right
cool so I'm also I used to have to wear
like a shirt and tied a 6-1 okay so I
took my drapes my tie off and tied our
arms to the bed hmm
and I'm laze about to get nasty yeah oh
you're ready for another get enough tea
in here this is what I'm into you
this is my room so either out of the bed
mmm yanked off her clothes she panicked
she didn't want anything to do with it
she was either let me go let me go let
me go
I'm not last comment that you trust me
or not let me go I'm tiny fat [ __ ]
untie me
oh so some women think they want it but
like is it this threshold yeah sometimes
they just want a little choke in a slap
but I feel like that same woman now
would be very much more susceptible to
what you did that probably because back
then obviously like said 6:1 that was 18
I was 17 18 that was years ago
so her thought process was even like a
rape fantasy was probably not even as as
much as way is now do you know I mean
hmm
so females females nowadays are probably
gonna be down for almost anything like
they will they will like I said the
threshold be higher and they're gonna
want it more they're gonna they're gonna
[ __ ]
whatever it is whereas ten years ago it
wasn't ten years ago like most of the
girls you were [ __ ] will probably be
about eighteen seventeen yeah yeah
thought they were here for they didn't
wait for it but they didn't know what it
was
yeah nobody was really in truth they
have not had enough sex to even reach
that point I hear you I hear you
shame rape so loosely and I'm so sorry
guys like it's not I don't advocate it I
don't do it I don't know anyone that
does it but you guys get what I'm saying
don't go report this video or this audio
or however you listen or watch into what
watching us but you get what I'm saying
like I feel like every woman has a rape
fantasy and I'm here for it of course
I'm here for of course I'm here for it
is this to me like I you guys already
know why I'm like I like rough [ __ ] I
like sexy [ __ ] so to me that's just sexy
but the fact that you want all of that
and you want that from me yeah manspider
hold that spot because we're banging
we're banging our with bang bang in with
bang bang in oh we're banging you know
what annoys me though mmm you will
understand this one I hate when I'm in
the mood for all of it yeah I'm in the
mood for all of it and I'm lap I want to
get crazy with it I want to do this I'm
talking quads work I want to do this to
you this to you this to you this to you
this to you it's like during the sex
this one before this is okay sex yeah
and then I know it's gonna happen yeah
we get into it and I intend to do all of
these things but as soon as it slips in
I'm not I don't give a [ __ ] anymore I'm
just here for the Wolves now Rock now I
I just want to [ __ ] now I just want to
carry on doing I'll do it I barely want
to change positions I just won't let
alone grab your throat I know exactly
I'm not putting out to be getting chains
and whips oh I know I know is that you
may know young because I still want it
so funny but this is the prep this is
here now all that other stuff is
subliminal
like it's irrelevant now let me tell you
a story
sell us [ __ ] a chick once and no so
we were lips and lips and lips in and we
were both still clothes at that time it
was get any he
and I was like you know let's just
[ __ ] stop let's just take our clothes
off now because we know what we've going
to do you know you know when you're just
lips in like slowly taking one thing off
that is sexy you know that is sexy but I
was so horny I was like stop just take
what your [ __ ] clothes off now
ain't got time to do all that sexy [ __ ]
because we know where it's end they're
not yeah yeah killed the mood for about
10 seconds yeah yeah yeah but she
understood yeah yeah yeah like sometimes
you just have to forego all that [ __ ]
bro you're you know what you're you know
why you're actually good as well mmm
because I've been there mmm I've not
said this whole I've not said like let's
just get naked or I'm not even acted on
it haven't just got naked yeah and then
the whole intensity of it and gets
ruined because you give her that that
half Chalcedon one yeah you just slide
the slider to the side pull your
trousers down to like here and then you
just [ __ ] with that all good like
yeah yeah and you'll never get you never
never get great sex for me it's just
it's almost I haven't a wank and they
they're great
sometimes they're great for like a
quickie yeah that one's if you've only
got 10 minutes and just then one good
boy they're amazing but when it's all
been the tensions been built up bill war
especially if it's like your first time
without someone yeah we were first time
in a while or whatever we haven't seen a
pub in ages take your socks off take
everything that come off you cannot see
me my socks always come off if you can't
see me naked a socks you just can't see
me that that's so emasculated
that's so funny bro making the socks is
the devil ah take your socks off cuz I
want to see you stalkers bro obviously
all of you I want to see all of it I
want to see all of you take it all off
ain't got time to waste some time
sometimes you know where you just see
red like you know when you're angry you
just see bread sometimes that's how
horny I am take you all off say about
the energy ain't got a time I go to
patients I'm gonna [ __ ] you do you know
I mean you lot know I just see red you
la Noah
Batman said ten seconds I got an
advocate right well I see red everyone
is understand
you mean I know what you mean I know you
mean that is [ __ ] hilarious Jesus
Christ bro I know that sometimes you
just have to ma'am you just have to yeah
someone needs to remind me that's when
dem ones the girl has to take the lead
for me she has to if I've been talking
the [ __ ] most mmm don't let me put it
into it till it till everything else is
done yeah bro because once I'm in I've
gotten everything I'm not leavin I've
forgotten every single little thing I
ever said I was gonna do because he
ain't got no time interview it's not in
the forefront bro it's not a priority
it's not the priority is my not it it's
no longer a priority this whips these
chains DS tie-in I've never tried any
what before have you not know oh I don't
have the energy it is amazing I can
imagine it's a mess I don't have you
know the meme big Mannion I don't think
you got the facilities for that facility
is for that big map I bet you can't bro
tie their hands together or a scientist
or wrists together or there's even been
times where I've had nothing this had
nothing but I've been like this is deep
into an Albuquerque there's been times
I've had nothing but I will grab her
hands pull my above her head and say
don't move your [ __ ] hands and every
time she moves her [ __ ] hands they're
getting back up there she might get
little slap in the face
don't move your [ __ ] hands
I know you mean that's funny
that's not exactly be yes but then once
all them ones are a sex is amazing
um you know what [ __ ] pizza me every day
I was talking so many other day you know
man obviously we the episode way back
when which one get yourself a sigh at
man yeah and also episode four or five
or something bro speaking to people or a
specific person is actually essential in
some regards mmm speaking to someone the
other day base if you know who this
person is mhm basically they were saying
like they're in in relationship it's a
female so they're in a relationship with
that man probably think all right now
you already know who it's just by saying
that and it's taking boxes fam it's
ticking boxes just everything they want
in that everything they thought they
ever wanted in a relationship is that
yeah this is this is everything that
they they fought they wanted in their
relationship yeah and they're like he's
a nice guy he makes good good money all
these things but it's just not taking a
problem it's not taking it and then
she's like what do I just allow him and
stuff like that and if I allow him like
she even says she's open about it she
was like I know obviously women stay
with guys for their money and obviously
is not just the money with the area but
that's just good it's a good part of it
it's not just that like he's a very nice
guy and she actually loves him as a
person yeah but she's like oh I block it
off of him and then nine out of ten
people would say yeah and even initially
I was out here just lock it off him and
then she was like put that like it
sounds horrible to say it but there were
act they will literally be a significant
decline in the quality of my life if I
break up with this person and it sounds
like I'm using him and suffered that by
I'm actually not like I do love him and
I'm saying like there'll be a
significant loss in my life if I get rid
of him and like yes the holidays will go
the car will go the house will go all
these things will go but and I also
would have lost that like a good friend
in my life of a breakup words person but
obviously there's also this element in
my life like the [ __ ] element and the
passion element and almost like the
loving someone yeah on emotion element
as well you can love someone because
they're they're a good person yeah and
you can
because they actually bring quality to
your life yeah and you could love some
that's why people fall in love with
[ __ ] as well because you could love
someone out of nothing but pure emotion
yeah you can love someone just because
you don't want to love them you don't
even like them yeah but you know with
him like she almost wants that in her
life as well and then bro I literally
was like I don't have the answer but
apart from gay aside man
apart from getting aside man this knows
no other this there's like there's
nothing else you can do and sometimes I
like I always at last couple years I've
always taken back I always like to take
a like a random standpoint regardless if
I actually feel this way yeah I'm always
want to say like if my answer would
typically be this thing I will always
try and put myself on the other side
yeah if I would say typically like I
said immediate reaction break up with
him yeah find someone that that takes
all the boxes yeah then I'm like okay
let's stand on the other side of it for
this that's that one the quantum code
[ __ ] side for a minute yeah I think
so you don't want to lose what these
things say if you're just a selfish
person say you don't want to lose all
this stuff so you don't want to lose
your house you don't want you like in
your head to say if you're thinking
[ __ ] why should I have to yeah like I
do love this person I do treat this
person right just me right yeah well I
don't want to lose all this [ __ ] like
why should I have to if you let's say
you stand on that side of the fence for
a minute then it's like I don't know
what you do then yeah I don't know what
you do it's crazy and then I was
thinking brah I said to it you actually
might have to guess I'm I'm waving
dokkan you might have to do it and then
if you do too it might actually be bless
your life actually let's just don't get
caught you a [ __ ] yeah but your life
might be amazing every box is now ticked
you've ticked every box you're fine and
as long as the guy isn't a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's gonna be here for it as
well
yeah like mmm-hmm as long as he's not a
home-wrecking [ __ ] which most guys
aren't or do you mean the side man the
sides are there for you to my domain as
long as the side man in a home-wrecking
con yeah and decides to [ __ ] [ __ ] up
just cause just cuz he can he wouldn't
do that though some guys know guys
because they might like [ __ ] fall in
love or like like the person that's your
[ __ ] problem if I'm seeing a go to
Scott boyfriend and then I fall in love
of her I'm not wrecking her relation I'm
not wrecking our home life like
that's my problem and you shall new
shoes with a man before yes yeah so you
fall in love is your problem yeah if I'm
catching fitness is my business you
[ __ ] up your feelings I know in your
other side man you yeah exactly and if I
can't handle them I need to back out you
need to bounce yeah I need to break up
with her then yeah and I did get on with
my life cuz imma [ __ ] on yeah and I
can't handle it that's fine I'll deal
with that in my own way I'm not gonna
start messaging my man that's some
[ __ ]
I'm coming to you as a man just to let
you know imagine bro imagine getting a
TM imagine getting that DM well I'll be
[ __ ] your girl dear yeah how much you
as a boy that big man just to let you
know I've been holding that pom for ages
now for ages cuz I'll say what benefit
are you gain for telling me because you
[ __ ] dick Oh what benefit Ernie I'm
getting from telling me or burn
everything
oh right well fine pull up pull up will
show me your location because how day
before I knew everything was fine
yesterday we were blind yesterday we
were blessed she gonna be [ __ ] you
tomorrow and I wouldn't have no
inclination bro and bless and our
relationship is probably better because
of you so you've just ruined it varied
up forever you only for yourself and
you've ruined it for her you ruined it
for me if you like let's say he comes
through laughs I'm [ __ ] her for the
last six months I'm not gonna lie to you
well that's funny cuz the last six must
have been the best six months oh my god
last expose me the best thing about my
[ __ ] life and now you ruined my life
row but they very well could've been so
funny was so true because now she's
self-aware of a relationship she's
self-aware of what I bring to the table
yeah she know she's getting one box
ticked over here but she's yet nine over
here yeah and now she respects me and
she she loves me and she understands
what I bring to the table and she loves
me for it yeah and we're happy we're
happy we're happy now that you've
exposed the thing she's got none of that
what she can still have you but you
bought what she's got one box tick now
now she's got one because she doesn't
know she doesn't really know you
like you like that she just wants the
would she want stick and I see one box
bro am i straight after and now she's
probably because now she's been getting
satisfied with my man she's probably
more inclined to come home satisfy me
yeah now she's been sucking me off
because she's getting satisfied last six
months the head has risen the head up
their head games went up and up and up
and she's been practicing on your toward
as well so the head game is through the
roof six months that's so funny
that's so funny God are you open to open
relationships
oh what a question but in a sense that
let's say you've got a pond like you and
your partner obviously you are the main
thing but if you are open to open
relationships the person you are open
with like the third party can never
interfere like it has to be someone
outside of your like group no I mean so
would you be would you be open to that
and do you think if you had a partner
your partner be open to that it's a
tough one probe I've had this
conversation in here before I can't
remember I can't remember but like it's
something that I like to think I could
firm mmm it's something that I would
like I'm open for everyone to get the
best experience yeah out of their life
like in as far as I'm concerned this is
my kind of atheist standpoint but when I
die I die and that's it yeah
and I realize that most things happening
in my life in the places that I am in my
life and what's happened in my life like
I've experienced so much bad [ __ ] yeah
and very few things or very few good
things have happened to me based on me
making a conscious effort to be a good
person you know I'm saying yeah like
very few good things have happened don't
get me wrong some have reaped the
benefits of being a good person in some
regards in a lot of regards I've I've
got fuck-all from it yeah so in that
respect I'm very much along the lines of
Bora [ __ ] it like let me just just be
happy in all aspects
let me do everything I can to be happy
like I said as long as I'm not hurting
someone else's feelings intentionally
let me do everything I can to have them
the most fulfillment now my life is I
can possibly get from it and if being an
open relationship in some regards could
do that because it means that I ain't
cheating on no one I'm experienced in
all aspects of life meeting different
people [ __ ] different people all
sorts like getting different
perspectives from everything and still
having the person that I love and care
about with me every single day yeah but
the pain in my chest
the paranoia every time she steps out
the yard every time she looks at her
farm like every time I hear a phone
vibrates yeah everything found
everything would drive me crazy and
crazy everything would drive me [ __ ]
crazy and I don't think I could handle
it and if it I'm not even a paranoid
person yeah it's just the fact that you
know for a fact what's going on yeah I'm
happy to be what you call ignorant yeah
like ignore it Liz it was bliss Bob's
been lied to me yeah lied to me it's
like lie to me from but it's when I know
shit's going down when I know shit's
going down how does how one person can
just sit there know that your government
your office that aren't going out
tonight even if she does lie to you and
says I'm going out with the girls
tonight like I know you're not fam I
know you're not you're going out to get
[ __ ] like [ __ ] L broth that's - so
in that regard I don't think I could do
it because I feel like the pain would
outweigh the pleasure okay
the pain of it all would outweigh the
pleasure for me okay and especially in
terms of like when do I get to say I
don't want you going out tonight can't
we just stay home and chill like when do
I get to say that you know I'm saying
yeah that's a am I now getting in the
way of your freedom that's a very good
stump I didn't think about because you
can say that in everyday context if she
says I want to go out with a girl xenoa
bear come on Mike I you stay home
tonight like that kinda thing yeah but
as soon as she's seeing other people
yeah and she's made plans with other
people other guys am I allowed to be
like nah babe come on my stay home like
am I now limiting your freedom yeah am i
stopping you having this open am i
closing the openness of this
relationship I don't know
and yeah I don't think I could do what
do you think I feel like if you had if I
had asked myself that question about
five years ago it would have been a
flower out now yeah I wouldn't even
entertain the conversation but I feel
like the older I get the more people I
meet the more experience I have in life
sometimes I feel like why not because of
the fact that like you said when we die
we like we don't what's gonna happen
let's be honest if I could just die in
that NASA or we could be not no one
knows but the fact is we literally have
one life to live and I am NOT saying
that I don't feel like I satisfy a woman
wholeheartedly or whatever but I feel
like if like this going back to the what
a Hummer which I've said it was but we
speak about when you speak about sex and
we say how much people enjoy sex like
the moment of sexy intro like am i
stopping someone from enjoying what they
think sex might be yeah in terms of like
being what's the word I'm looking for
engulfed in the euphoria of it because
my my engagement of sex could be sung to
someone it could be so minimalistic but
someone else it could be outrageous yeah
because everyone is different everyone
thinks differently everyone is different
when it comes to sex yeah yeah so I feel
like I would be open to the idea of
openness but within the same way if you
hadn't mentioned that that thing what
you said about I just the paranoia and
stuff how would I feel about it because
it works both ways cuz I don't know
whether she'd feel that as well yeah so
I feel like um it's not a no hmm but I'm
leaning closer to the maybe / yes yeah
when I asked you five years ago I've
been a nut yes because I realize that if
you're in a relationship you can't you
can't just think about yourself yeah man
do you know I mean you just can't think
about yourself you have to you have to
consider the other person's feelings
emotions experience what they want to do
blah blah blah
and let's say for example like
threesomes for example I we've discussed
that I've never had a threesome
everyone who doesn't want a threesome in
their life before they died you know I
mean but you have to find the right
person to do a threesome with it it
could spread and you happen but you go
on Hanabi meet two girls born that
ideal quinoa you know me that's ideal
but if you're in a myth that's a myth
but if you're in a relationship the
likelihood of you having a threesome is
zero I mean unless you entertain the
idea once you entertain the idea and you
actually like speak to your person at
your partner about it and you can kind
of see that it could be done then we're
getting somewhere then we're moving and
shaking you not I mean please know until
you actually explore that you never know
right
that's why I feel like in life you just
always have to you never know once you
try and I never want to be a what-if
person like oh what if I did that how
would things have turned out I just want
to try [ __ ] bro like if if my partner
was one sister or she was down to do it
Who am I to say in it because if she is
that something she wants to do then I
feel like I should like you said you
have to take the other standpoint and
see from another perspective like a
Beach water you see from the other side
and be like maybe I am hindering her
from reaching our full potential
sexually or yeah man yeah I mean rags
like did she won't tell me bro I just
want to [ __ ] you
pegye guy I just want to start I want to
put a [ __ ] strap-on on and [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of a guy like it would turn me
on so much she's never doing that to me
I'm never late by it
first and foremost bring it out into my
house my awful that's it boom I had to
stop you living your best life that's
not because we could get married and we
could die together yeah so that means
I'm categorically by me saying no I'm
telling you that in your life it's never
gonna happen
it you're gonna die and that's never
gonna happen I'm telling you that now
because we're gonna cuz we love each
other we're gonna have kids together
we're gonna get married everything so by
me say you know he's in your life that's
never happening why do I ever get that
why should I have I have the power to
stop to someone doing anything in their
life that's why I'm sayin man that's why
I say the older I get the more
susceptible I am to saying yes to Safi
yeah I don't mean because you just can't
obviously you you are the home story
only for like you said before but once
you're in a relationship it's a
two-month signal from where it's a dream
to work now I knew well you have to
really bounce off your journey to make
sure each of us get the best out of
their lives yeah yeah
best of everything I am more open to a
lot of people might disagree with me but
again that's your opinion that's the
life for you to choose to live in blah
blah blah but I just don't see obviously
I see that the negatives per se behind
it but with every negative that's porn
you can always flip something yeah right
exactly exactly like everything
everything I just said that stops him
wanting would that would stop me wanting
to have an open relationship I have an
equal amount of benefits like doing
exactly so yeah man stuff I would have
to leave it I'll have to leave it up to
the Tamar government she'd have to come
to me and say this is what I wanna try
so I want to do and then hopefully ah um
I really have enough what do you care
what do you say security van I'm not
insecure enough so hopefully have it
yeah
hopefully I'm not insecure so insecure
that I stop that and just say that
because I don't want to feel this way I
don't want to be pounded about this I
don't want to be paranoid about that
yeah something I want to try like and
for her to even bring that up to you
would have taken so much fun yeah
exactly so I think I'll be more inclined
to say yes if it's something that she
bought up yeah and then I can be like
all right cool man
let me think about let me because then
he gives me the opportunity to deal with
the hardships first yeah and then I can
think about the benefits but if I'm
doing it just because I think I want to
[ __ ] chicks yeah and then I'm going to
my girl out [ __ ] this man oh I have an
open relationship anymore head what I
think advice [ __ ] exposing you and I get
blindsided by all this bad [ __ ] I'm
gonna break down yeah of course
so yeah she came to me and said this is
what I want to do then I'm home lobby
lap and they're also in intertwined with
like the negatives
there's also slight positives in there
as well like understanding the fact like
when you're knowing your girls out doing
a thing yeah it can kind of it might you
might reignite sign that you seen your
girl something that you haven't seen a
long yeah yeah of course
like I was watching a show on Amazon
Prime is it was Vikings
mm-hm it's been a few years now I just
watched it because the other day and in
one of the episodes monkeys these
Vikings [ __ ] that that's all and I say
these Vikings [ __ ]
he's got him and his missus they're
[ __ ] yeah and they stopped by he's got
slave like an actual slave yeah so he
goes into his slave and says prov like
do you want to jump in I mean my wife
were wondering do you want to jump in
and he's like he's a monk in it in zis I
can't like it is against Gordon really
stuff i man said like look at her breath
and she's like wrapped up in her bed
sheet
she's freeing up the leg and says like
you sure you don't want this he's a
prophet looker like he sure don't want
that and I was thinking he must be
looking at his missus whilst he looks at
this other guy wanting his missus he
must be looking for good what she's boss
yeah look at my man sweating from he's
ready to go against God to [ __ ] my girl
like in a weird way there must be a bit
of a turn-on
yeah and I've listened to a podcast
before about a guy who's been in an open
relationship yeah and he used to have a
used to almost give when he knows his
girl's been out and I come back when he
does [ __ ] his girl he's got a new fire
in there yeah cuz he wants to put down a
letter know why he's the main guy well
here's a reminder why and the main guy
oldest or your other little toys their
little side things like this is your
home and this is why it's your home this
is why yeah this is it so he used to
have like a little alpha metallic like
I'm gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] you I can't with a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you so you remember and I was
we can I can see that I can see the
appeared in that as well so yeah I don't
know man if it ever comes up maybe
you'll happen but I don't know man
another side of that as well as that
I've spoken to you about it people don't
even see this is an open relationship
because it's such a cup it's such an
undercard but like guys have a much
easier time acknowledging stuff like
that
if your girls going off of another girl
oh yeah so if your girls by yeah and she
wants the experience fingers of other
girls yeah it's a lot easier right guys
to accept it they will never see that as
an open relationship that that's the
thing they don't see is cheating that
relationship is just a ting girl does if
if that turns you on by all means
baffles me a battle the fingers it I
have the same thoughts about it's not a
threat
my my my head it's not a threat because
it can flip even if it's a let's say a
gay couple two gay guys hmm
they're in a relationship but one of the
guys goes out and like [ __ ] a girl the
other guy is not gonna really take it as
a threat threat but if you guys aren't
[ __ ] another gay guy is that oh [ __ ]
you've been replaced now yeah yeah yeah
like yeah I understand what you mean
it's like how do I say it like say the
difference between getting a promotion
and move into a different department
like if you move if you're getting
promotion like you're on top of people
now yeah like I'm on top of you man yeah
and then your colleagues are a bit like
this guy thinks he's a hot [ __ ] why was
he leaving us now but if you're just
moving from here this department to this
department lady everyone still boys yeah
everyone still bread trees I will oh
cool yeah because you're just trying
something different so I guess I can see
that
I guess exam be replaced right man fair
play um I'm at the [ __ ] know my deal
so let's go let's get it which one you
got for us today right I think this
might relate to what we're talking let's
go
am I the [ __ ] for wanting my husband
to tell people he has a wife I know I'm
gonna like this one
what said I said this again am I the
[ __ ] for wanting my husband to tell
people he has a wife that make sense
yeah it makes sense but I'm just like
why is this even a question
right I need the context so it he works
with men 90% at the time but sometimes
their wives come out to the property and
then he has a social worker that visits
one to two times a week and this an
inpatient facility who works out okay
cool so except for silly with patients
and [ __ ] yeah and then there's a female
social worker that comes once or twice a
week
mm-hmm several months ago I asked the
Social Work I asked about the social
worker his words were she's fat and not
attractive at all you have nothing to
worry about
lo and behold we run into this gal at
the store a couple weeks ago she's
drop-dead gorgeous her body's a 10 and
she has an effect
just smile did he introduce me nope so
after I throw a pregnant [ __ ] fit I
finally shut up he tells me that they're
never in the office alone
people are always around bla bla bla so
here we are and he has another broad
hitting him up with time flies with you
so here we are and he has another broad
hitting him up with time flies when
you're having fun messages online kissy
u winky face is you name it once again I
asked about her oh she's x y&z wife
nothing to worry about
mizuchi as a hands down Qi I'm firm in
the belief that if you don't set
boundaries of someone yeah that they
will push the line not drugs it's been
two days and I'm still upset I'm
pregnant
I'm getting bigger by the day he blames
on my hormones and I blame on the fact
he won't say any [ __ ] boundaries in
his work life which in my mind will
eventually lead to an affair emotional
or physical that being said am I the
[ __ ] for wanting to set boundaries
with these woman's a reminder that he's
in fact very married I think there's
angles to this I feel like I feel like
she's gone off on it like the main issue
is he categorically said that this this
social worker whatever is fat and ugly
yeah they bump into each other she's got
a 10-10 body her titties are out smiling
from then you know he's cheating so all
of this extra stuff thing is you say
that you say that it depends on because
I know from experience if I'm spending
time with a girl mmm involuntary time
yeah so I work with her yeah if I just
want a stress-free life more time I'm
more likely to say she's ugly to my wife
yeah because I just don't want to deal
with aren't be but yeah I don't want you
asking about a woman in my work I just
can't be asked for it yeah um obviously
later down the line man's getting
messages like time flies when you're
having fire first band that's live in
the same chick that's a different yeah
and man take that someone else's wife
first of all social worker aside that's
a line he's [ __ ] this person yes I'm
fine there's nobody
you can say in in everyday context that
says time flies when you're having fun
we have said we had sex because there is
no there is no way in hell let's say for
example you're married and your missus
has text me time flies when you're
having fun and let's say my missus for
example sees that she knows I'm [ __ ]
your missus right there's no
conversation that needs to be had ranks
cuz there's no context in which your
missus would say that to me Rex why
would she say that brags and she found
wink faces why would she say that I'm
baffled as it is that why would she say
that
rough man's a categorical cheat you're
pregnant he doesn't want to [ __ ] who
he's [ __ ] other women I feel like
that's the long stage yeah in that I
don't know what's going on with the
social worker he could be [ __ ] her
maybe not maybe he just wanted to avoid
the stress of everything bring it up and
in terms of this next [ __ ]
he's definitely [ __ ] her he's [ __ ]
her he's definitely [ __ ] her but I'd
one thing I didn't like what she said
was that I'm a firm believer if you
don't set boundaries with someone
they're gonna push the line I don't like
that whole concept I don't like the
whole fact when people say like ah like
I feel like it's a it's a night it's a
fing among women where they think that
you know when private example you know
when goes to say stuff like they get
angry when the guy wants to go knock on
lads holiday yeah or stag do yeah they
think if he's in a scenario where it's
easier to cheat he's more likely he's
more likely completely false yeah if I
want to cheat on going I'm going to
cheat if I don't want to cheat on you
because I love you I'm not going to yeah
it doesn't matter where I am or what I'm
doing I could be in Dagenham yeah if I
want to cheat on you big man I'm doing
it if I want to have sex with someone
else I'm doing it doing where I am and
there's no there's there's nothing that
can make me cheat when I don't want to
yeah I'm not gonna accidentally fall in
this [ __ ] yeah I'm not gonna do it if I
don't want to do it it's not going to
happen happen so I hate with this whole
like you need to set boundaries in him
you need to make sure he's not coming
out of his friends yeah he's not going
on lads holidays [ __ ] annoyed all of
these situations that he might cheat
like what the [ __ ] is that
but what even is that like freak man
this boundries thing I don't like it
like I'm a firm believer if you don't
set boundaries
they're gonna push the line like what
are you talking about she's also talking
about saying boundaries with him and his
people at work so kind of they're
pushing the line Bank like he's not
saying boundaries with these women at
work so they think they can message him
x y&z so he needs to be telling them he
has a wife so for one you should be
telling people you go away oh right
because if you if you are if you have
any sick if you have any form of contact
with someone on a regular basis and they
don't know you're married
like there is there is doubt there is
something you want to [ __ ] yeah your
thing is like there's something going on
to the fact that you've avoided the fact
that you say your mouth because that
just comes up in conversation of course
especially if she's pregnant from so
you're having a baby with someone and
it's just not come up like come on come
on
so yeah there's something going on with
that that being said these hoes don't
give up they don't give [ __ ] he can tell
he can tell them til he's blue in the
face she blaze don't give up somewhere I
just don't give a [ __ ] and as watches
that sounds it's so annoying I so
horrible we are the [ __ ] victims as
much as us as much thicker than getting
for my pregnant wife we are the victims
bro because some boys don't care they
just couldn't care she could be in labor
she'd be like come [ __ ] me now bros i
just just don't care they just don't
care they just don't care and they and
then they'll flip it and there will be
the cons that message your wife
afterwards rugs they won't like you know
come and get this [ __ ] I'm gonna tell
your wife that you've been doing
they'll suck your dick dry until one day
you don't show up on time they know wake
it up here your wife's waking up with
the three messages I've been coming to
you as a woman bro women are conniving
bro so yeah I'm mad he should be telling
people he's got wife but that same time
in the job yeah he sought from the jumpy
that's that's kind of shady yeah
but regardless if they're worried I want
to [ __ ] him they trust me they're going
to and if he wants to [ __ ] them he's
going to and wrote this whole boundary
sting babes it works anything you have
to take things as on when they come it's
like what sorry
I was just gonna say yeah you have to
take things as on when they come I'll
win your man's getting messages yeah
same time flies when you're having fun
wink these boundaries things out the
window no the pregnancy things out the
window the social workers open window
categorically this is what's happening
right now and your man's [ __ ] about
yeah right regardless if he's telling me
right hard or not like you need to air
all that your man's are cheap right so
like this am I the [ __ ] thing you're
not an [ __ ] you're just a bit from a
mug if I'm honest you're not mug but
you're concerned about the wrong wrong
sit they all concern about the wrong
[ __ ] that's why I said she wrote so much
like the boundary like that's not the
point the boundaries isn't the point you
Amanda clear cheek bro your man is a
cheat and what was gonna say is that the
more you set badger set kids for example
if you tell kids ten times don't go
outside the more you tell them the more
they can want to go out there more than
one a good a Cosby trying to go outside
there gonna be ups I don't want to go
outside that's what I'm trying to say
right well the more and more you
pressure him about boundaries per se the
more he's gonna want to do something
else
there's a ting madness that fing you
know more pressure you put on him the
more he's gonna resent you and what to
do he was someone else
of course cuz you just hate you for it
then you give a man trust me like from
experienced women if they're listening
give a man all the freedom in the world
and I promise you in for a good
relationship do not restrict your man's
movements don't be checking in on his
phone
don't be grilling him or give him mad
freedom and I promise you you will come
back to you one hundredfold like don't
give him stress men just want to live a
life stress-free dress all they want to
do all they want to do is live a
stress-free so don't be don't be
worrying about boundaries this and
telling them that like trust me oh wait
what any words vice versa was not
obviously man them give you a woman
freedom it was way too [ __ ] righteous
it works both ways my man damn as well
being secure peace occurring what you've
got like if you're my woman wants to go
out wearing whatever she's wearing let
her worry because at the end of the day
that's probably how you met right and
you were entitlement I saw obviously
she's confident and comfortable enough
to continue to wear that because she's
secure enough to know that she's not
gonna go out there and do crud
because if she feels good in herself and
she wants the way
what's the look good she wants to be
center of attention sometimes and go and
have fun
do you know hold us but come on boy
that's the thing man same ways you can't
restrict your mind if your minds gonna
cheese gonna cheat you and if he cheats
you just got cheated on you're gonna
have to move on infer me I'm sorry
that's just life it's true if a man was
to cheat he bochy rights and if a woman
say with woman for we must reach all the
time for a woman was to cheat my god she
will cheat us because it's easier for a
woman to have sex than it is for a guy a
woman can Holly you today and be like
come [ __ ] this [ __ ] stuck you send that
to ten guys and ten guys eleven will
come back eleven it would show up one
boy if I send if I say to ten chicks
come get this thick no one showing up
I'm probably gonna buddy prob'ly like
one or two were probably entertain it
and they program oedema show up right I
mean because women could woman control
it so if a woman was the cheap bike or
GG in rags Jean yeah Rapide Rapide
Rapide e-wrap calm